what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder of
where we talk all things marvel and mcu
and doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is the next big film that is
coming from marvel studios now if you
have not seen spider-man no way home
this is your spoiler alert because we
will be talking about what happens in
spider-man no way home now a bunch of
rumors have been going around about
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness but that's exactly what it is
it's going to be a multiverse movie and
it's going to be madness it's going to
be crazy so there's just a ton of stuff
that could possibly happen especially
since spider-man no way home brought
back toby maguire and andrew garfield
spider-man so of course after spider-man
knowing home we're starting to wonder
could there be cameos in multiverse of
madness and who exactly could they be in
this video we'll go over the top cameos
that i want to see in multiverse of
madness and thank you to bespoke post
for sponsoring this video more on them
in a bit spiderman no way home really
did change the game because again they
brought back toby and andrew and they
did it in a film that wasn't exactly
truly about the multiverse yes the
multiverse came into the picture in the
movie and that's how all of the villains
came in but first and foremost it was a
spider-man movie this movie however
doctor strange 2 is literally called
multiverse of madness and some of the
cast members have literally said the
word bonkers when referring to this
movie which leads me to believe that yes
there will be some crazy cool cameos the
question is who and like i said the
possibilities are endless they brought
back original spider-man in spider-man
knowing home so they could bring back
some original characters from the old
fox universe so that means we are
talking the original x-men the original
fantastic four deadpool could show up
and make his mcu debut in fact i have an
interesting theory about that and then
of course there could be different
variants of characters that we already
know and new characters could possibly
be introduced now we already know the
cast that is confirmed to be in the film
of course we have doctor strange himself
then we have wang christine palmer carl
mordo making his return america chavez
making her mcu debut the scarlet witch
and who we believe to be strange supreme
and then we have gargantos who is
mistaken for schumachorth a lot we're
not sure why it's not schumachorth and
why it's gargantos maybe the studios
don't have the rights to use that
characters but this is definitely
gargantos and then of course there are
some side characters like dr west who we
really aren't going to focus on because
the excitement comes from the big names
who could show up for example right now
a lot of people really want tom cruise
to show up as iron man there's a ton of
fan art for him and a lot of people are
fan casting him and here's why
originally marvel studios approached tom
cruise to beat iron man in the mcu
before robert downey jr but he turned it
down so if the multiverse was real there
would be a world where we would have a
different universe where tom cruise
would be playing iron man he would be a
variant and this is where things get
very interesting and very excited and we
have a lot more to talk about but first
and a big thank you to bespoke post for
sponsoring this video bespoke post is a
monthly membership club that delivers
awesome top shelf cool products to you
each month such as outdoor gear bar wear
kitchen and home goods clothing and even
more they sent me three boxes myself to
have and i am personally in love with
these boxes this is the taran in the
terror box you get the ultimate tool
this is actually an award-winning knife
based off the japanese hoary hory which
is a multi-purpose gardening tool and
the really cool thing about bespoke post
is that they purchase 90 of their
products in the boxes from small
businesses in fact this is made by bare
bones which is based in salt lake which
is right around the corner from me
the next box they sent me was the
retreat and it had something in it that
i've always wanted a hammock and it also
came with an on-the-go blanket this is
perfect if you go camping or hammocking
or if you just want to put it up in your
backyard and the last box they sent me
is the trailbox which i really do love
and it has the book surviving the great
outdoors which is filled with
indispensable tips on surviving in any
environment it also has a pocket saw
with nylon straps it has a gut hook
knife which is a beast of a blade
designed for hunting and skinning it has
a paracord bracelet and it comes with a
field box to keep your outdoor goods
safe and organized every box has about
70 dollars worth of things in retail
value but only costs 45 dollars when you
become a member you take a quiz which
helps them determine what to send you
each month you get assigned a box but
you get to preview what you get before
it ships out so you can one keep it two
swap it for a different box or three
skip the month entirely for no charge
only pay for what you want to get twenty
percent off your first box click the
link in the description and enter code
cosmic wonder 20 at checkout or go to
bspk.me
cosmic wonder 20. now continuing with my
variant theory tom cruise showing up as
a variant version of tony stark iron man
the same situation kind of happened for
emily blunt emily blunt met with marvel
studios about the role of black widow
before scarlett johansson had landed the
role ultimately emily blunt would pass
on the role because she was already
contracted for another film gulliver's
travels so again if the multiverse was
real in real life we would have a
different universe where emily blunt was
actually cast as black widow and the
same actually goes for her husband john
krasinski the person that everyone in
the world wants to play mr fantastic
including myself i think he would make a
great mr fantastic but originally john
krasinski auditioned for the role of
captain america now this isn't somewhat
of the same situation that tom cruise
and emily blunt had because marvel
studios wanted them for the role however
marvel studios wanted chris evans for
the role of captain america and that's
what they got but still an alternate
universe exists somewhere out there
where john krasinski actually landed the
role of captain america originally so
when exploring the multiverse and
multiverse of madness and since it is
going to be madness we can assume
they're going to explore many different
universes perhaps we stumble upon a
universe where all of these characters
are actually played by these other
actors i think this would be really cool
and pretty meta however i don't think it
would be as cool as bringing back some
of the original x-men and some of the
original fantastic four and i have a
little bit of reason to believe that at
least some of the x-men could be
returning because over a year ago
patrick stewart admitted in an interview
that he met with marvel studios
president kevin feige this was in late
2020 but he said i met with kevin feige
a couple of months ago and we had long
long conversations and there have been
moves and suggestions which include
charles xavier here's the problem if we
had not made logan then yes i would
probably be ready to get into that
wheelchair one more time and be charles
xavier but logan changed all that and i
totally get all that however it could
just be a variant of the character which
means nothing would undo the death of
logan it could still be charles xavier
played by patrick stewart but from a
completely different universe the same
thing goes for wolverine hugh jackman
has stated many times that logan was as
well the end for his character and him
playing wolverine both of the actors
said that since both of their characters
died in the films they kind of put them
to rest in real life as well but now we
have a film where they could come back
and reprise their roles as the character
and not undo anything that has been done
in the past they don't have to undo
their deaths and even though they say
they're not coming back remember andrew
garfield also said that he wasn't the
werewolf but there he was in spider-man
no way home just saying and not to
mention i think toby maguire spider-man
could be coming in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness as well if you
think back to spider-man 2 with toby
mcguire when doc awk first shows up the
daily bugle is trying to think of a name
for him in which dr strange is thrown
out there and jjj says that's pretty
good but it's taken telling us that
there is in fact a doctor strange in the
universe where toby maguire comes from
doctor strange that's pretty good
but it's taken
and although tubby might not be a main
character of multiverse of madness since
there is a variant of doctor strange in
his universe it would make sense that
maybe we see him again now keeping it up
with original actors returning since we
are getting a new blade in the mcu it
would be kind of cool to see wesley
snipes return as blade and bring ryan
reynolds with him for those of you who
haven't watched the blade series ryan
reynolds is in blade so it would be
really cool to see the original blade
wesley snipes and ryan reynolds pop up
alongside of him now something i would
really love to see is a cameo from the
fantastic four even if it's just one of
them and if i had to choose i would
definitely choose chris evans because
that would just be hilarious i would
love for chris evans to cameo as the
human torch and it would be great if
somebody made a joke stating like hey
look it's captain america but he would
have no idea what he's talking about and
say nope i'm the human torch of the
fantastic four i think this would be a
fantastic opportunity now i'd also love
to see jessica alba and the rest of the
original fantastic four as well and
since they're scientists they might have
already kind of stumbled upon the
multiverse themselves so if doctor
strange came through a portal it might
not even be that big of a surprise to
them now with deadpool i think there's a
good opportunity here to get him into
the main mcu i don't think it should
happen in this movie but i think he
should be somewhat teased i think
deadpool should learn about the main mcu
in multiverse of madness whether that's
him accidentally stumbling into the mcu
or dr strange and the scarlet witch and
everybody else kind of going to his
universe and he finds out what's
happening whatever it takes to make him
realize that there's a main mcu timeline
and his timeline is not the main one
since he can break the fourth wall it's
a perfect opportunity for him to go well
my timeline sucks i gotta get to that
timeline and then in his actual movie
deadpool 3 they could do a deadpool
kills the fox universe movie this is
where deadpool could go on a huge
killing spree killing all of the old fox
x-men characters fantastic for everybody
from his universe and then he ends up in
the mcu i think that would be a pretty
cool segway especially since he can
break the fourth wall now here's
something i think a lot of people will
really like since charlie cox returned
as matt murdock aka daredevil and
spider-man knowing home and vinnie d
returned as kingpin in hawkeye i think
it would be incredibly cool if we saw
other characters return in multiverse of
madness like jessica jones luke cage
iron fist and of course jon returning as
the punisher i'm not sure if all of
these actors are going to be back in the
mcu like daredevil and kingpin but if
they're not seeing them in multiverse of
madness would still be really really
cool although right now it's kind of up
in the air on whether or not the netflix
series were actually canon to the mcu
we'll get more clarity on that down the
road now as far as new characters are
concerned i would love to see somebody
like dr doom introduced in multiverse of
madness because he is a mystical
character and possibly the greatest
marvel villain to ever exist but he has
ties to doctor strange in the comics he
has ties to wanda he has ties to
mephisto and i think if we're having a
movie that is widely magically based it
would be a great opportunity to bring
victor von doom into the picture now the
multiverse of madness could probably
bring a lot of different villains and
heroes that are new into the universe
but i think you got to be careful i
think that most of these if they happen
are going to be cameos which is fine
they stay in their own universes or get
caught in ours a little bit but i think
when you introduce a lot of new
characters at one time it gets a little
bit messy so i'm good with just sticking
to doctor doom being the new one that
comes in and these are the characters i
think will be in multiverse of madness
and who i really really would just love
to see and let me know who you would
love to see in multiverse of madness in
the comments down below remember it's
the multiverse of madness anything is
possible and this movie is going to be
bonkers so let me know what you think in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof